and it was about two in the morning and
I couldn't breathe I woke up and I
didn't know whether it was covered and
anxiety panic I didn't know and I woke
up in the night I'm like
and I could not breathe and well I
thought I was gonna die and I remember
praying please do not let
endorsed by a steam celebrity Dr Chris
Steele MBE from the good morning ITV
show in his celebrity Dr Maxine this
exceptional product has been touted as a
remarkable natural alternative for
erectile dysfunction in men and female
sexual arousal disorder in women
formulated with an impeccable blend of
100 natural active ingredients
functioning similarly to pharmaceutical
Alternatives like Viagra for men and
phlebancerin for women our ingenious
formula and extraordinary pills enhance
blood flow relaxing blood vessels and
smoothing muscle tissue
brothers and sisters and dear friends so
I'm somebody who likes to go out and eat
a lot alhamdulillah Speakers Corner on
Sundays I come to edgeware Road and
hamdullah being here I've seen Paul
before his conversion to Islam many
times walking here with my wife Angela
we've met him we've seen him so this is
Brother Paul the police officer
I saw your um story in my head I was
thinking he was already a Muslim for
some reason but then you said you
officially like Turkish other in January
January this year I was at home
and it was about two in the morning and
I couldn't breathe I woke up and I
didn't know whether it was covered and
anxiety panic I didn't know and I woke
up in the night I'm like
and I could not breathe and well I
thought I was gonna die and I remember
praying please do not let my daughter
find me that's how bad I put in afraid a
voice in my head from nowhere that's
never happened before a voice in my head
said put the Quran
I've got my tablet I've never heard this
voice before I put my tablet on and I
Bismillah
I breathed I cried I laid in my bed and
I slept like a baby the next day I went
to the mosque I said
best thing that's ever happened to me me
obviously as you know focus on teaching
new what was the new reverts how to play
Salon how's your journey with Salah what
I do you know I I will recite after you
yes and I I know that you know and
there's there's certain words that I'm
learning so much I was saying the prayer
in English yes um if I forget the Arabic
version but again it's just a slow you
know for all of us brother you as you
know this is just it's a work in
progress and exactly you know and I'm
learning every day and there are words
you know that I do struggle with but
alhamdulillah it's just about learning
and I know obviously the likes of
yourself and other people we have the
two pillar project so in our project
we're on the first one is
the second one is the second philosophy
sandwiches
which is not fun but it's amazing so
we're gonna give you that guy the cream
and we'll send it to you inshallah you
can go to our website.com and we'll send
one free to your house but if you do
ever need a one-to-one session which we
do that as well which you said
alhamdulillah the brothers where you
live I already got sorted out that's
good use the prayer mat it is
life-changing inshallah do you ever have
any struggles with the Salah because I'm
Gonna Make You said that you wanted to
know if you can pray it in English or in
Arabic yeah so what I do you know I I
will recite affect you yes and I I know
that you know and there's there's
certain words that I'm learning
um
I I so much I was saying the prayer in
English yes um if I forget the Arabic
version but again it's just a slow you
know for all of us brother you as you
know this is just it's a work in
progress and exactly you know and I'm
learning every day and there are words
you know that I do struggle with but
alhamdulillah it's just about learning
and I know obviously the likes of
yourself and other people
I honestly I am humbled you know I know
you know by
being chosen by Allah because I really
believe I've been chosen you know people
said then why did you go to Islam
hello but it is
the peace the love what I've been given
from from our people from our you know
from this community it's just fantastic
and I just want to thank everybody you
know because it is humbling when I have
every day I have little children six
seven years old come around welcome to
Islam I have Elders coming up to me
welcome to Islam so alhamdulillah you
know it's just it's an amazing it's been
an amazing journey I know I'm at the
right at the beginning of my journey and
I feel you know I just gonna get you
know I'm going from strength I thank our
donors who you know help us buy the the
prayer mats and mail the best you guys
people like brother Paul there's sisters
out there as well our aim is to connect
them back to Allah through Salah
inshallah may Allah bless you guys till
next time
you can go to our website.com
with an instructor male or female or you
can go and order your free Salah guided
prayer mat which will be delivered it to
your very door you can book an
instructor for free we can come to you
and teach you inshallah in the London
area and the surrounding areas inshallah
or we can send you a guided prayer mat
which has all the instructions you can
learn how to pray instantly and we want
that for you because the second piece of
Islam is the Salah brothers and sisters
and the scholars have spoken that this
is a matter of cover believe for this
belief the fact that it's a discussion
of belief or disbelief shows how severe
and how important the matter of Salah is
and anyone that has belief and gratitude
to their lord brother sisters how could
they neglect Salah we call you inshallah
to pray in Salah with salahplus.com book
your session or audio guided